SPEAKER 1: Jose Ocano, who
is the Pacific Regional
Director of Best
Friends Animal Society
and also oversees the NKLA
initiative by Best Friends.
So without further ado, Jose?
JOSE OCANO: Hi, everybody.
Get my clicker.
So my name's Jose.
I just moved here in May.
So I'm brand new to all of
these traffic and parking
situation in LA, from Tucson.
And so a little
bit about my story
is I grew up in Tucson, Arizona.
So first of all, you're welcome.
That's me as a child and my dog.
And I literally
grew up, literally,
on the wrong side of the tracks.
That's my house.
And you know, it was actually a
really tough place to grow up.
And my mom was acutely
aware of the environment.
And so she was
really adamant that I
had the least amount of
exposure to really bad stuff.
And the way she
kept me occupied was
by allowing me to have
whatever animal I wanted.
So I had dogs and
chickens and goats
and a peacock at one point.
And I learned a whole lot
about just responsibility
and connecting
with these animals.
And you know, I never
actually understood
what that would mean in
the big picture of my life
until something really sudden
happened-- when I was 16
and my dad passed away.
It was quite sudden.
And I think when something
like that happens,
you just naturally start to
question your own mortality.
And you start to
question why am I here?
And one of the things that
I started to think about
is all of the people
that did grow up
in the neighborhood
that were my age,
the people who I either
went to school with,
the neighbors, the
neighborhood kids.
And I just started
realizing that there
was a trend of like drugs, in
jail, or dead, some of them.
And I just was unsure why
that didn't happen for me.
And I remembered
the following day
I was going through pictures
for this collage in preparation
for the funeral.
And I actually
found that picture.
And I realized the difference
was that I had this dog.
And I realized, I
connected the dots,
that animals had saved my life.
And I made this kind
of promise to myself
that I would spend the rest
of my life dedicated to saving
as many animals as possible.
And so I finished
high school early.
And I thought I wanted to
be a veterinarian until I
took O Chem and realized
that's not going to happen.
You're not smart
enough for that.
And so I thought,
OK, well, I still
want to work with animals
in a shelter possibly.
So I went to a vet tech school.
And I found myself working
in a small practice.
And I was really
bored, honestly.
And so one day I got this
task that no one ever wanted.
I actually jumped at
the opportunity for it.
We had to go to the local pound
to drop off some paperwork,
some licenses.
And so I was, like,
please send me,
because I can't handle one
more of these boring exams.
So I went to the
local animal shelter.
And I remember growing
up, going there as a kid.
And it was just--
it really was a pound.
So I walk in, and it's dark,
and it smells, and it's loud,
and it's kind of depressing.
And I thought, I
should work here.
So I don't know what
that says about me,
but I really just thought
this would be a great idea.
And I applied for a job there.
And like any government
job, it took six months
to just even get an interview.
I thought, I have already
let go of that dream.
And so I got the job.
And it was--
I think it actually--
there it is.
That was actually my first
week working at the shelter.
So I remember walking
in and thinking,
like, I'm here to save animals.
That's the whole reason.
I'm going to get to save
so many animals working
at this shelter.
And the supervisor's
interviewing me,
just asking me questions.
I already had gotten
the job, onboarding me.
And then she started asking
me a really interesting line
of questioning.
And the first one is--
so have you given
injections before?
And I thought, yeah, as a vet
tech, I do that all the time.
And so she's like how do you
feel about restraining animals?
And I was, like, I'm
comfortable restraining animals.
That's something
I do all the time.
So she says, OK, stop.
Come with me to the
back real quick.
And I thought she was just going
to give me a tour or something.
And she takes me to this
room in the very back,
and there's a line
of dogs there.
And she drops this giant
black toolbox on the table.
And then she opens it,
and I see what clearly
is like euthanasia solution.
It's blue-- like, all of us who
work in this industry call it.
It's very distinctive.
You know exactly what
you're looking at.
And I looked at her
really confused.
And I'm, like, well,
I'm not a doctor.
Because I came from a practice
where only doctors were
allowed to do that.
And so she was, like, no, no.
This is going to be your job.
And I need you to do
all those animals,
and you have 10 minutes.
And I thought, OK, well,
let me try and understand
why this is something that
they're thinking needs
to happen.
And so I asked simple questions.
Why is this happening?
What's wrong with these animals?
And so she just
starts to say, well,
that one sneezed, and they were
all kind of in the same row.
And we got 100
dogs in yesterday.
And there's no room for them.
And so this is your job.
If you can't do it, then
don't waste our time.
And I realized, at that time,
they lose so many people
that they really did not want
to invest any time in any one
unless they could do this.
And I quickly realized, oh,
this is what this job is.
It's actually not
about saving animals.
So she kind of said, if you
can't do this, just leave.
And she walked out.
So I'm just looking at these
dogs for the first few minutes.
And just-- my heart
beating so fast.
And I called my grandmother.
And I tell her what
they're asking me to do.
And she said something to me
that's carried through with me
my entire career.
And she said, you
have two choices.
You can leave, and that's OK.
You don't have to do this.
But someone has
to stay some day.
If you really believe that
you can change something,
then you're going to have
to work in a broken system.
And you're going have to
do what they ask you to do.
And I got off the phone.
And at first, I
was going to leave.
But then I really thought
about the fact of--
I want to help animals.
This is where they're
coming in, and this
is where they're dying.
I'm going to have to work
in this broken system.
And so I did what they asked
me to do for many, many years.
And so I worked as what I
thought was a kennel tech.
It actually turned out the real
position, the working title,
was Euthanasia Technician.
But they don't
post that online--
shocker.
And I was a part of that
for many, many years.
But I always believed that
we could change things.
And so I slowly
got to know people.
And little by little, I started
trying to make gradual changes.
And I worked my way
up within the shelter,
always believing that I
could change something
that we could change something
because what we were doing
was not OK.
And I mean I did a lot of--
I broke a lot of protocols for
the sake of saving animals.
We had what we called the
Underground Railroad of rescue.
So what I learned
is that they had
three shifts for euthanasia--
the morning, and afternoon,
and at night.
And I realized that
the night shift--
usually that was where
the most amount of animals
were to be euthanized, but
all the supervisors were gone.
Everyone was gone, actually.
It was just the two closing
euthanasia technicians who
were there to do everything.
So we would-- because we were
really smart about this, too.
So we would pull the
euthanasia solution.
We'd pour it down the drain.
So you could see, if
they did drug inventory,
this is really bad,
against so many FDA things.
But you do what you got
to do to save animals.
And out the door, they'd
go to a reputable rescue.
And we had this whole
system of how we were
saving hundreds of animals.
And I just thought we really
shouldn't have to save animals
in the dead of night.
That's ridiculous.
But we did what we had to do.
And over time, through being
in new positions-- and so then,
when I became the
rescue coordinator,
I was able to implement
protocols and practices
so that animals
had a shot at life.
And I remember in the
beginning, it was very much so--
you have two hours to
get this animal out.
That's intense, especially
when they're giving you
a list of 100 animals that my
job is to get out in two hours.
But I was happy just
the chance to have it.
And then two hours
became two days.
And two days became a week.
And then, I eventually
convinced the medical team,
you could treat these
animals, and if you prescribe
the medication, I will give it.
I will make that part of my job.
I will find time to do that.
And little by little, we
really started to change that.
And it began this total shift.
So actually, that is a picture
of the pound where I worked at,
and that's what
it looks like now.
And it just is kind
of this representation
of how far we came.
You know, when I
started there, we
were a shelter that
took in 30,000 animals.
And the vast majority
would come in the door
and out through a cooler
and end up at the dump.
And now it's a place
where less animals come in
because of spay-neuter.
Because we changed
the idea that people
actually want to help animals.
They don't actually want to turn
their animal into a shelter.
So how do we become
supportive of that, as opposed
to just judging them?
And so through all
those different things,
intake went from
30,000 to 17,000,
and now the shelter
is saving 90% of them.
So it's really cool.
And some of the things that
happened throughout those times
is we had this bond
where we basically
said we want a new shelter.
And it was for $22.5 million.
And I don't think any
of us ever thought
this would actually
pass, because there
were so many things up for
bond election that year.
And everything failed
except the animal shelter.
And I actually--
because I was there
in the implementation
of going for the bond,
but I left for
this job right when
they were breaking
ground and building it.
And I actually just saw it for
the first time two days ago.
I just got back from Tucson.
And it's this beautiful
building that's
built around life-saving--
and how far we've come.
And this is just kind of
an indication of where
we are, actually, as a country.
There is a shift now happening
where animals aren't just
a lawn ornament.
They're just not a commodity.
There these sentient beings that
are part of life, our lives.
To the point where even people--
I know lots of people who don't
own an animal because they just
don't feel like they could give
that animal the time that they
need-- that shows that even the
thoughtfulness of them bringing
on an animal into their life.
So things were
going really great
at [INAUDIBLE] Animal Care
Center this time last year.
And I was talking
to Jeff earlier,
because we have a common
friend in a woman named Candy.
And so Candy works
for Best Friends.
And I met her at a
conference when I was
speaking at it in Las Vegas.
And so she was in town, because
her mom lives in Tucson.
And she's, like,
let's go for a drink.
And I thought, fun.
Of course, I will
always say yes to that.
And we go-- and through
this conversation,
she's, like, have
you ever thought
about working for Best Friends?
And I was, like, no, I'm
so dedicated to my team.
And I think part of
the reason for that
is when you're bonded by a lot
of sadness, a lot of us who
worked there, worked
there in the trenches
during the hardest time.
And we kind of
brought it up together
and changed the
shelter together.
You feel this deep sense of--
I can't lead this team ever.
And so it was not
even an option,
but I said I'd be open to it.
And she took that
and ran with it.
And before you knew it,
I was in conversations
about a regional
director position.
I had no idea where it would be.
I had no idea that it was
going to be in LA or anything.
And for months and months,
we kind of talked about it.
And I was just so
unsure what to do.
Do I stay and help the
community oversee the shelter
and actually get
to enjoy actually
working in a lifesaving
shelter that we
dreamt about for over a decade?
Or do I go to Best Friends,
this organization that
has been around
for 34 years, built
around kindness, compassion?
What's really neat
about Best Friends--
and I've always been a fan--
is Best Friends started off
with this group of founders
to just build the largest
sanctuary in the country.
That's what they wanted to do.
And that's what they did
initially, because they just
have a firm belief that
no animal should die
because it doesn't have a home.
And so they started the
sanctuary, which still exists.
It's in Kanab, Utah.
And it's still the
largest sanctuary.
I think there's
over 2,000 animals.
It's in the most
beautiful place,
and so much life
saving happens there.
But over time, Best
Friends started
to have regional cities
and regional programs.
So we have programs here in LA.
We have programs in
Salt Lake and in Kanab.
And in New York City,
we have one in Soho.
One in Atlanta--
and we're always
looking at where can we have
strategic presence in order
to save animals' lives.
And so there's all
these incredible things
that I just love
about Best Friends.
And so it was really, really
hard to figure out what to do.
I'm here.
And I think one night
I was thinking about--
how am I going to
make this decision.
And I started to think
about this number.
This is how many
animals, to this day,
die every single
day in shelters.
4,100 animals, healthy,
treatable animals
in this country are
dying every day.
And I just realized--
what would that 16-year-old
kid who realized my purpose is
to save animals' lives--
what would he do?
And that was a no
brainer for me.
It's all about having the
greatest amount of impact.
Because this comes out to
1.5 million animals a year.
And that's progress.
Because when the
founders started,
that number was actually
believed to be 17 million.
So 34 years ago it was
Now we're at 1.5 million--
that's still way too many.
And the thing that's so
crazy, when I talk to people,
they have no idea this
is still happening.
And we'll talk a little bit
about Southern California
later.
But in Southern
California, it's happening
in all of our backyards,
especially here.
And so I made the
decision to come to LA.
And what's really neat
about where we live is--
so Best Friends always
had presence here.
Best Friends was
here doing a lot
of different types
of cultivation--
whether that was just getting
supporters and telling them
about all the cool things
that were happening
at the sanctuary in Utah.
And so it's interesting.
When I talked to
Francis Battista, who
is one of the founders, and
he's the chair of our board,
and you know, he
started with this idea.
And then they were
doing tabletops here
at different grocery stores.
And now we have these huge
adoption centers here.
So it's always cool to see the
founder's reaction to things.
The thing that I think is
so interesting about LA
and why I was so excited about
coming and ultimately selecting
this program and this region
is because of the NKLA
initiative--
No-Kill Los Angeles.
So we were here.
We had a really good
understanding of everything
that was happening in
LA, the amount of animals
that were dying in the
city shelter system.
So LA, actually the
city of Los Angeles,
has one of the largest shelter
systems in the entire country.
And when the initiative
first started bubbling up,
it was, like, 54,000 animals
were going into that shelter
a year and about 20,000
of them were dying.
And so their save rate was
in the 50s, the high mid-50%.
And there was a really
unique opportunity
with the pet adoption and
spay and neuter center.
So that actually was going
to be a seventh city shelter,
because there's six of them.
So they built this
shelter with bond dollars.
And then when the
recession hit, they
couldn't afford to staff it.
And so it sat vacant.
This lifesaving center sat
vacant for quite some time.
And that's when
they put out a bid,
or put out a request to
see who would be interested
in operating the.
Center so one of
the things that is
really cool about
Best Friends, and I've
said this to you earlier,
Best Friends has balls.
They really go for it.
And so they thought, let's
put in for this contract,
and let's operate a
giant shelter in LA.
Because that's what it is--
it's designed to be a shelter.
And we'll do it in partnership
with the City of LA.
And we'll bring on all
of these key partners,
and we'll create a coalition.
And we're going to
work in sync together,
and we're going to collaborate,
and we're going to coalesce.
And we're going to save animals.
And we're going to get
the city shelter system--
and we're going
to get to a place
where they're
saving 90% of them.
And that 90% is important.
Because you'll hear the
word no-kill a lot--
and so the baseline for no-kill
is that 90% of the animals
are being saved.
The thing that I'll say about
no-kill and 90% is that--
one of my good friends,
Arlen, said this.
And it always stuck with me.
90 percent is the
floor, not the ceiling.
It's just that first benchmark.
Because you have
places like Austin
who are saving
97.7% of the animals
that are going into their
large shelter system.
So that was where this
whole coalition came from.
And the idea was that
all of our efforts
will be to directly pull animals
from the city shelter system.
And so that's what we do at
the Mission Hills location
in the valley.
So we take in thousands of
animals from the city there.
We rehabilitate them, and
then we adopt them out.
And we do offer
public spay-neuter.
That's now actually
provided by Snip LA,
a local nonprofit in town.
And as that was happening,
there was an idea
about the NKLA Pet
Adoption Center,
which is not too far from here.
It's on the West Side, opposite
Sepulveda and Santa Monica.
And what's so interesting
about the adoption center
is that half the animals
are Best Friends,
and half the animals are
from different groups.
I don't know if any of you
have worked with animal rescue
or have been involved?
There's a lot of opinions and
emotions on how to save lives.
And I always say there's
1,001 ways to save animals,
and necessarily, none of
them are necessarily wrong.
But because of that, people
are visceral about how they
think animals should be saved.
So to get several
dozen organizations,
rescue groups to all agree
to be in one adoption center
and agree to the same
adoption application
and adoption philosophies,
which our adoption philosophies
are people are good.
People do good.
And so you're not going to
have to qualify yourself
to get an animal, and give me
your first born and a blood
sample.
Because there are
some places that
can be really, really intense.
I have a friend who-- they're in
the process of adopting a baby.
And they're, like, it was
harder to get our dog.
[LAUGHS] And I was,
like, I believe it.
And so it took a lot
of coordinated effort
to get everyone to
be on the same page.
And that's what the
NKLA Adoption Center is.
So another 5,000
animals get adopted out
of this adoption center.
And it's really unique, because
what's different about it
than Mission Hills is--
Mission Hills was
built to be a shelter.
It was built with all of
those kinds of things in mind.
The NKLA Adoption
Center was built
around what is the animal's
experience going to be there?
And what is the person's
Because a lot of times-- who
here has been to a shelter?
Have you guys been?
Most of the time,
it's overwhelming.
You're on sensory overload.
And when you're on
sensory overload,
you might not be
in the best space
to adopt an animal,
to find your animal.
And so everything about
this space is about--
how do we show animals
in the very best light?
How do we use technology
actually, as well,
to kind of promote
these animals?
The thing that is great
about Best Friends
is you'll never see
animals behind bars
in a kennel with a really sad
song playing in the background.
We always show them out of a
kennel, really good pictures,
trying to get that
smile off them.
Because that is what people
are going to be drawn to.
So when you walk into the
NKLA Pet Adoption Center,
it has that feel.
You want to be there.
When I work there
half the week, I
love working there, because
it just has such a good vibe.
And you can kind of see
that when people go in--
they want to be there.
Some people just go
there to hang out.
And I think that's so
important because animals
are so intrinsic to our lives.
And so the more we kind of
redesign how we show animals--
I think it's going to be
really important how we engage
the people moving forward.
So these are our main
initiatives here in LA,
and we are making huge progress.
So when we started
the whole initiative
the total save rate--
it's the measurement
for that 90%--
for dogs and cats was at 57%.
And last year,
it's closing at 87.
That's huge, to get to those
metrics in a five year period
is really incredible.
And actually, when you
look at dogs versus cats,
you'll see that
dogs actually are
exceeding that 90% threshold.
With cats, we have
so much work to do.
And that's because LA is very
different in a lot of ways.
But in LA, there is a
lawsuit against the city
that doesn't allow them to do
progressive cat programming.
So for instance, there
is something called TNR.
Have you guys ever
heard of TNR before?
Trap, neuter, return-- it's
the idea of feral cats.
Everyone is familiar
with what a feral cat is?
We call them community cats.
So it's just a cat
who lives outdoors.
And so the best thing
to do with those cats
is to trap them, spay-neuter
them, vaccinate them.
You cut the tip of
their ear so you
can see that they've
been part of the program,
and then you put them back.
Because those cats
are not social,
so they're not
adoptable, and so they
die in shelters because of their
behavior and their temperament.
In LA, they're not allowed
to do any of those kinds of--
they're not allowed to do
those programs for animals that
enter the city shelter system.
So because of that,
animals aren't
getting spayed-neutered in
the community at the rate
they need to.
And when those
animals do go into LA,
it becomes almost a
near death sentence,
unless you find some other
loophole to get them out,
which is really, really hard.
So for instance, LA alone
gets 10,000 kittens a year--
10,000 kittens,
eight weeks or under.
And when you get those kittens,
especially when they're
four weeks and under, which
is a huge percentage of them--
most people also don't
realize that the majority
of those tiny baby kittens--
they die.
Because there's no way to
feed them-- the amount of time
they need to be fed.
And the staff doesn't have the
resources to care for them.
So unless a rescue group
or Best Friends pulls them,
they don't have
lifesaving options.
And so because we can't
run the kind of programs
we need to actually
solve the problem,
the kittens are
just-- every year
there's more and more kittens,
or the population sustains.
So with dogs, we've
seen dog intake go down,
and we've seen live
outcomes go up.
And because we haven't been
able to do what we really
want to do with cats, we
just see them coming in.
And so we have to
basically implement
programs like nurseries
and different things,
which are lifesaving.
But they're band-aids
to actually solving
the real problem.
But we'll continue to do that,
because it's the right thing
to do to save those
animals' lives.
So it's really,
really incredible
to see how far we've
come in the past five
years of the initiative.
And so this year everything
we do is built around data.
And that's where I think Best
Friends is really unique.
So much of animal welfare
is built around anecdotes.
Or I feel like people return
animals because of this reason.
We don't even have a good
system for many years
of actually collecting,
well, statistically--
when are animals
returned, why are they
returned, what
are the zip codes?
You know, actually using
data to solve the problem.
And so everything we do with
Best Friends is actually
extremely data driven.
It's the basis-- whenever
I'm talking to groups,
and they start with I feel, I'm,
like, what does the data say?
Not that your feelings
are not important,
but there is a data answer
in what you're about to say.
So let's actually solve
the problem correctly.
So we just went through our big
strategic planning for 2018,
and everything we did was
built around data and trends
so that we can be the most
resourceful with the resources
that we have.
And the future is actually
looking really, really cool
for Best Friends.
So I think it was in 2016.
I was in Salt Lake City at
the Best Friends National
Conference, and I was
just there as a speaker.
And I'm sitting there,
and Julie Castle--
who's our Chief Development
Officer, marketing,
communications, all
of that good stuff--
goes onstage and
says, we're going
to launch a 2025 initiative.
And we're going to
get the whole country
to no-kill by the year 2025.
And it's kind of funny, because
I remember thinking-- god,
I feel bad for that
team of people.
They're going to
have so much work.
Well, it's now my
work in this job.
And that's where, with
the 2025 initiative,
one of the things we did
was look at national data.
And we realized we don't
even have a good metric
to describe the problem.
We're describing the problem
possibly wrong for so long.
Because two years ago, if
you looked on any website,
it would say three to
four million animals
are dying every
year, total guess.
I have no clue where that
number even came from.
So we did this really
intense data discovery
where we basically looked at
every county in the country,
every shelter, and collected as
much data as we possibly could.
So we could actually see
how many animals are dying,
where are they dying,
why are they dying,
and what are we
going to do about it.
And so my role as a
Pacific Regional Director
is to kind of focus
our initiatives
in California, Washington,
Oregon, Hawaii, and Alaska,
so that's my part of the country
that I'm responsible for.
And I was so surprised when I
looked at Southern California.
So Southern California accounts
for 10% of all the known
deaths in the country.
And it makes sense,
because Southern California
has, in general, some
of the largest shelters
in the country.
So you have San Bernardino
that has a massive intake,
LA County, Bakersfield.
All of these different
places that so many animals
are going in there.
And because there's that high
concentration, a lot of them
are not making it out alive.
So we have a lot of work to
do in Southern California,
but the reality is
it really is doable.
That's the thing that, when you
look at 2025, and I thought,
I don't know how that's
going to be possible.
But when you actually
look at the data,
and look at-- if we just make
a 2% impact every single year
in our region, we'll get there.
And that's a really
doable thing.
And that's something
that I really
appreciate about Best Friends
is the fact that we utilize
the data to actually inform
all of the strategies
and all of those
funding priorities.
Before, perhaps we'd have
organizations who would say,
I want to do this
program because I
think it's really cool, and
it'll save a lot of lives.
We now know-- let me look
at the data from your COUNTY
and let me see if that
would be more impactful.
And in fact, I've had to make
some tough decisions sometimes.
And look at, actually,
you guys are OK,
and I need to put
this resource here.
Because that's actually where
they really, really need it.
But it's a really exciting
time in animal welfare.
And this is where
it's so important.
This is my pitch to all
of you to get involved.
Because Best Friends and just
all of us crazy animal people,
we're not going to do it alone.
We really truly aren't.
We're not going to achieve it.
We're not going to sustain it.
We need people who are
going to really help.
And there's so many
ways you can help.
It's adopting.
Who here has animals?
Go get another one.
No, I'm just kidding.
I have two, and
I'm at my wits end.
It's even fostering.
That's a temporary commitment.
Especially in LA,
fostering of kittens--
you have all these
organizations who
are willing to pull these at
risk kittens from the shelter,
but they need people
to just let them
crash at their place
for six to eight weeks.
If you have a spare bedroom,
a litter box and some water,
it's pretty easy,
actually, to save kittens.
That's why when I see,
when kittens are dying,
it's so easy.
The solution for them is they
need a bathroom and some time.
Or any room-- and some
time to just grow up
to be big enough to be at an
adoptable age, which is usually
two months.
And even volunteering--
you know,
volunteering is
really important.
We have so many
different opportunities
within Best Friends,
the local shelters,
lots of different
rescue organizations
can always use volunteers.
And of course, we can
always use donations,
because there's a lot
of work to be done.
And there is a lot of that
work requires resources.
It requires funding.
Groups who want to do
even more, or groups
who want to do something but
need some seeds to really grow
it.
At minimum, I feel like
everyone can advocate,
like, you know more now.
How many of you, I'm
curious, about this.
How many of you knew that this
many animals were dying a year?
How many of you knew
that Southern California
was one of the worst places
in the country for animals?
Most don't.
I for sure didn't.
I think I associated
Southern California
and I saw some of the
really good shelters.
And I also associate--
there's a different kind of
resource in Southern California
that there's not, because of the
entertainment industry, that's
not prevalent in other
parts of the country.
And so there's really no
reason why Southern California
is in one of those really
hot spots for the country.
So at minimum, talk
about it to people.
Because people just
have no clue about it.
My biggest takeaway
is that it's possible.
It really is possible.
And so I invite all of you
to go to BestFriendsLA.org
and learn more.
That's it.
All right.
[APPLAUSE]
AUDIENCE: Sorry about that.
So we had, a couple
of years ago,
a talk about another
book that was actually
very upsetting to me.
And I kind of want to
get your take on it.
But it's from the perspective
of cats are evil in all forms
and have to be destroyed, that
TNR programs are not working,
are not effective,
and we basically
just need to eliminate
the domesticated
and feral domesticated cats.
What do you think about?
JOSE OCANO: He's so right.
No, I'm just kidding.
[LAUGHTER]
He's really wrong.
This is always my answer
and my experience.
We've been trapping and
actually killing cats
as a best practice for decades.
We did it at the shelter
that I started at.
And every year we just saw more
and more and more coming in.
It just doesn't work.
And you know, it's
really interesting,
because a lot of times these
arguments come from the birding
community.
Because the idea
is these cats are
going to kill these
birds, especially when you
go to places where there may be
endangered species or animals
that are on the protected list.
And so they get very amped up
about the cat conversation.
And I feel we're in this
place sometimes-- why is it
either/or?
I love birds, too.
And the only way to actually
stabilize and reduce
cat population-- the only thing
that's been proven is TNR.
So having less cats in
the community in general
means that there will be
less cats eating birds.
And so I'm always baffled when
I talk to some of those folks.
We want the same thing.
We truly do.
The group that filed the
injunction against the city,
that's one of the big reasons.
It's just the
impact on wildlife.
And it's not either/or.
We can totally save
cats, save birds.
And actually, the
only way to save birds
is by saving cats this way.
Which book was it?
AUDIENCE: It was
called-- hold on.
I had the email up here.
JOSE OCANO: Was it recent?
Was it one of those
recent "Cat Wars"?
AUDIENCE: It was, yeah, 2016.
October 2016-- it was "Cat Wars,
The Devastating Consequences
of a Cuddly Killer."
And they were basically--
JOSE OCANO: Such a great title.
AUDIENCE: --that the cats
had been responsible--
like, personally responsible
for the extinction
of many species of birds.
And my problem with
the talk, aside
from the fact that I like cats,
is that they didn't really
have any evidence of that.
How did they know it
was the cats doing that,
not the people who moved
into those communities,
not the deforestation,
that we're taking away
the plants, the trees that
the birds need to live in?
They're just saying,
oh, no, it's all cats.
JOSE OCANO: Yeah,
community cats just
get this giant target on them.
And I don't know if
that's just because it's
an easy kind of
assumption to make.
But there actually isn't--
even when you look at the
data that they provide,
and anyone who will analyze it,
you'll see tons of holes in it.
There's all these
other variances
that are not even taken
into consideration
on why a certain population
of bird is decreasing.
But they just run
with the cat thing
because it fits their narrative.
And there's a real
inability to look
beyond that, because they're
just holding onto it so tight.
AUDIENCE: And I think the thing
that people don't appreciate
about the wild cats that we
have, the feral cat community,
is that they're actually helping
with other problems like rats
and mice and other small animals
that are pests in our yard.
And people kind of forget about
the whole Black Plague thing.
It's too long ago.
People don't remember it.
JOSE OCANO: Yeah.
I always think of cats
as, like, cats are just
part of the landscape
in the community.
I mean, yeah, there's a
squirrel that's really
annoys my dog all the time.
Are we going to
start an initiative
to kill all the squirrels?
You know what I mean?
At what point--
where do you stop?
Because there is something
like the circle of life.
Birds eat insects.
Save the insects.
You know what I mean?
Where does it come and
end, if all life matters.
AUDIENCE: Anyone?
Oh, sorry.
Sorry.
AUDIENCE: No worries.
So on the topic
of community cats,
I've seen a number of feral
cats myself in my neighborhood
and this bothers me.
It bothers me
immensely, to the point
where I'm pretty much willing
to just put my money where
my mouth is, find
a rescue group,
and just fund their
TNR in my neighborhood.
My worry with
something like that
is I know one of my neighbors,
a few houses down, they
have a cat that is not
spayed and neutered,
but it is their cat.
In that sense, I'm worried
like, hey, what's my liability?
What's my thing?
I'm kind of assuming that
you have a general answer.
Like, you guys have been there.
You've done that.
You've dealt with
some owner who said,
no, I have purposely kept
my cat unspayed, unneutered,
and now you've just
destroyed that.
AUDIENCE: Is it chipped?
AUDIENCE: I don't know.
I haven't caught the cat.
That would be my first question.
Because if it's not
chipped, then it's
fair game for a TNR program.
JOSE OCANO: And the cat's
running around at large.
I mean, I think that's--
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
JOSE OCANO: Yeah,
and I mean, if there
is no indication that there is
an owner, so there is no chip.
And that's something, even
when we trap cats, you know,
we're scanning for microchips.
There's nothing that indicates
it's an owned animal.
It is just a loose
cat, you know?
And so there is onus on that
person who allows their cat
to go out and free roam.
But also the cat has no
identification, you know?
And so we practice TNR
programs all over the country.
I think we're actually
like the expert on it,
because we do it really well.
My first introduction
to Best Friends,
actually, was we received a huge
million dollar grant to start
a TNR program in Tucson.
And there was no
liability, necessarily,
on the animal
shelter, on the groups
who were also participating
it, or on Best Friends.
Because they're strays.
And they're at
will and at large.
So do it.
[LAUGHTER]
AUDIENCE: Can I get
your business card,
so you can hopefully get me in
touch with a group to do that?
JOSE OCANO: Sure.
AUDIENCE: Do you return the
cat if it's already chipped?
If you catch a cat
for the TNR program,
do you just give it back,
or take it back to the owner
if it's chipped?
You don't spay or neuter it?
JOSE OCANO: Yes.
So if an animal actually were
to come in with identification,
then we're going
to do everything
we can to find that owner.
Usually that involves
a holding period.
So in the shelter
system, if you brought
in a cat that normally would
qualify for that program,
and it had a chip,
then you just have
to hold it the mandated
time and do the things
that the ordinance says.
Which is you have to make
attempts to contact the owner,
so you're calling the
number that's associated.
You're sending a letter.
And you have to hold it
for a minimum time period.
If no one comes
forward, then the cat
would get TNR'd that
way, and then go back.
And you know what's interesting
is cats in animal sheltering--
actually they die
really a lot of times
disproportionately to dogs.
And there's lots of
research out there
that shows by TNRing the
cat and putting it back,
it's way more likely
to go home because it
knows where it lives.
People don't reclaim
their cats in shelters.
I think the average
rate is maybe 1% to 2%,
while dogs is in the
20% to 25% nationally.
And so, when a cat
goes into a shelter,
it's very unlikely that its
owner is ever going to find it.
But if you actually put that
cat back where it came from,
the chances are so
much more higher
that it's going to go back home.
So it's always interesting.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: I have two questions,
but they're fairly quick.
The first one is a personal
thank you for using data.
It tells a really
powerful story.
So that's helpful.
My question, though, is we
talk a lot about dogs and cats.
I'm curious about other
animals and initiatives
that maybe Best Friends is
involved with for rabbits
or other animals as well.
JOSE OCANO: Yes, so at our
sanctuary we have livestock.
We have birds.
We have wildlife.
But at one point,
Best Friends was
trying to do it all in so
many different aspects.
And we realized we need to
have a concentrated effort.
And so because it's
cats and dogs that
are dying in shelters,
that's where we decided
to really focus in our efforts.
It doesn't mean that
after 2025 or something
that an initiative won't change
to include something different.
And certainly when
we were in Houston
for the hurricane,
which was intense,
people would come with animals
that weren't cats and dogs.
And it wasn't, like,
sorry, we don't do that.
If they came to us, we're
going to figure it out,
or we'll refer them
to someone who can.
But it was really a
conscious decision
to really zero in on
something so that we
could be the most
impactful as possible,
so that our efforts
aren't diluted.
AUDIENCE: My other question
is, I think, even quicker.
Which is, Strut Your Mutt--
super cool event.
I had a chance to
participate in it one year.
Can you talk about
that event a little bit
and how we can get involved?
And maybe if there's
2018 events on the books.
JOSE OCANO: Yes, I
don't know if they're
on the books for
Strut Your Mutt.
But Strut Your Mutt is
actually really, really cool.
So we do this
giant kind of event
where people can bring
their own animals,
and they can fundraise.
And all of the
proceeds that we bring
onboard actually go directly
back to the rescue groups.
So for instance, if I was
a rescue organization,
I could start a Strut
Your Mutt campaign
and get all my friends to join.
And they all show up,
and they register,
and they donate, and
100% of those proceeds
goes back to that organization.
So Best Friends is
a national brand.
And we are really good
about telling our story
and telling other
people's story.
So it's important for
us to use our platform
to also serve our
network partners
and the organizations
that are hand-in-hand
with us doing a lot of
the work in the trenches.
So Strut Your Mutt is
something really fun.
You can volunteer.
You can bring your own animal.
Even if you don't,
it's just a cool place.
It has a cool festival vibe.
Even going to hang
out is really neat.
So actually, I'll give you
information as it gets closer,
and then you can disperse it in
case anyone wants to volunteer
or partake in the festivities.
I think I have to emcee it.
I've been trying to
dodge it, but I'm
pretty sure that's happening.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
JOSE OCANO: All right.
AUDIENCE: You mentioned
that when you were initially
working at the shelter
that you at midnight
you would be trying
to get these--
JOSE OCANO: Broke all
of our protocols, mhm.
AUDIENCE: Uh huh.
Why was there any resistance
to handing these dogs off
to these rescue groups?
JOSE OCANO: That is
such a good question.
I think it's twofold.
The first is this idea
that the community is
like public enemy number one.
People suck.
People are bad.
These rescue groups,
they're just hoarders.
You know, they don't really
want to help animals.
The secondary thing is when
you have to euthanize and kill
tens of thousands of animals--
I'm thinking of the generation
who was there before me--
they had to find
ways to make that OK.
So even suggesting to
do something different
makes them have to deal
with what they've done.
And I've been in
that exact boat.
You know, I remember when a new
program would come on board.
And my gut reaction
was always, like, I
can't believe we killed all
these cats all these years,
and the solution was so simple.
So I mean, the
shame that you deal
with working in this environment
is real, and it is so deep.
And that's why, even in my
role, I approach everything
with curiosity.
I'll go into the worst shelter.
I'll look at their
data, and then,
like, literally everything
going in there is dying.
And I approach it
with curiosity.
For me, it's just,
like, I'm on that quest
for knowledge,
free of judgment--
because I don't
know their reality.
I don't know what
their experience is.
I don't know how many really
good people went in there
and left.
How many people have
just been beaten down.
And that's why I think it's
so important that, even when
we interact with the shelter
systems who aren't doing
the work that's
saving animals lives,
I always start with
compassion first.
You know, it's very
rare, and it's not even
in my nature to make it
adversarial because I was them.
And that's part of why I tell
that story about my first day
to a lot of people.
Because it equalizes and it's
my way of connecting to them
and saying I really
truly get it,
and it doesn't have to
be this way anymore.
Because the other thing about
folks in animal welfare,
you really convince
yourself, and maybe there's
some truth to it--
no one understands.
And so you're siloed.
And so the only
people that you have
are people doing the same
things validating you.
And so it becomes this
really unhealthy cycle,
and then you get cemented
in your belief system.
And so so much of what we're
doing, even with Best Friends,
is working with these shelters
in a non-adversarial way,
and saying--
there's another way.
And let's do it together.
And it can be a slow
or fast as a process--
preferably fast-- as
you're comfortable with.
The end, yes?
All right.
SPEAKER 1: We promise you don't
have to public speak anymore.
JOSE OCANO: Thank you.
AUDIENCE: Today.
JOSE OCANO: Today-- today, yeah.
Well, thank you so much.
I really appreciate
the time, guys.
[APPLAUSE]